all right ricardo
ricardo where'd you grow up where you
from originally uh originally i'm uh
well i was born in montebello at a
beverly hills hospital or beverly
hospital and i'm originally from san
gabriel valley la puente
specifically and uh tell me about your
family growing up
um
what i can say about my family because i
i don't really know much um
all i know is that um
i have a mother
uh who
had an addiction problem her whole life
so she was pregnant with me
and throughout the nine months that i
was in her stomach
she used and abused
um there was times i was told that you
know she tried to kill me
you know but it just wouldn't happen uh
my mom
you know was uh
growing up right an area skid row
uh she liked heroin methamphetamine
basically anything she could inject in
her veins you know she would use while i
was in her stomach
and then um
nine months come around you know and uh
time to give birth
and uh i was told that uh
she gave birth to me and when she gave
birth
she was sick
going through withdrawals so that when
she had an opportunity to leave
she yanked everything off of her didn't
sign my birth ticket and took off
your mom had a baby and split yeah in
the hospital yeah well she had me and
then i had another brother who passed
away from aids
i've only met him once
and then
my dad i guess had took me
take it but he was a big alcoholic so
from my understanding um
i was passed over to my father he signed
my birth certificate he was an alcoholic
and he left prostitutes
so what he tried to do was
if he didn't have any money you know he
he used me as a as a bartering system as
layaway
and uh my grandma found out about that
because uh there were times where uh he
always dropped me off with my grandma
you know just to clarify for my viewers
that what you're saying what you're
implying is your dad
would use you
um to get what he wanted to get money
yeah sexually yeah
with with men that want to have sex yeah
women whatever or whatever
and then have sex yeah on his own with
prostitutes yeah yeah okay
and um
i was little you know and it was things
that um
i don't like thinking about you know or
uh
you know like the [ __ ] he did you know
yeah it's a horrible childhood for a
young man um
[Music]
only way my grandma found out was
because i would talk about it not
knowing that it was wrong or
you know i would just speak about it you
know and i would be like what are you
talking about you know i'd explain her
you know
she kept me
and uh
i really had no guidance you know but
but because of uh
things that i went through and stuff
like that it was hard for my grandma to
tell me no
because uh she loved me
so um
i ended up with my grandma
and uh
he disappeared
never heard from him nothing and
randomly one day someone's banging on
the door and it's him and he's drunk
and i remember
my older cousin telling me uh
he tells me he's all kid in the room
he's off you're coming through i'm gonna
[ __ ] your ass up
i said why say who's at the door and he
said don't worry about it
so my uncle comes they open the door i
hear arguing and [ __ ] like that and then
uh
it was my dad you know they whipped his
ass in the kitchen and [ __ ] like that
you know he came back because he was
drunk trying to get me
you know
um
but it didn't work
so they whipped his ass called the
police and stuff like that and
you know and then uh one day um
i was told that uh
i guess he was walking down the street
or something like that
drinking
he got to about the 10 freeway and just
died right there on the spot
uh congestive heart failure walking down
the freeway yeah which which is
terribly dangerous anyway
yeah he died from alcohol poisoning and
congestive heart failure
so um
growing up um
[Music]
i was uh like in between like families
and stuff like that
like my grandma i would go with my
grandma and then from them i would go to
my dad's brother
my tea and them you know and and
and so in doing that
you know i'd come over here and then
come back to my grandma you know and act
different she didn't like that because
you know they were teaching me things
and telling me this and i come over here
you know and i can't live like that here
you know and
well
it's crazy how
my mom
used drugs and stuff because i didn't
know about
her abusive drug you know using drugs
and [ __ ] like that i didn't know
anything about that
i just remember you know being told that
um if i don't change my life that i'm
gonna end up just like my mom
not even knowing who she was or what she
did
and what's crazy is is for a minute i
was following in the footsteps
because i was doing everything she was
doing
i was stealing
i was slamming heroin
methamphetamine
you know i'm currently on methadone
right now
um
but it's just it's just crazy how it
works you know how i don't even know her
no nothing about her and i'm like doing
the same [ __ ] that she was doing yeah
you know there's definitely a genetic
it yeah i don't get it i don't
connection
yeah i i don't understand it man so then
i started getting in trouble you know
and
started hanging around with the wrong
crowds and stuff like that and um
i had a we had another brother another
brother his name was ivan
um
he was a favorite you know
he was the the favorite of them all and
never went outside nothing like that you
know what i mean one day he left
to go spend at somebody's house
16 years old
he left to go to somebody's house and
i asked him to wait for me because i was
bringing him jack in the box showed up
he was gone
i called him no answer early in the
morning we get a knock on the door
the police
and uh they handed me his wallet and his
cell phone
told me that he died
that was the first time he ever we ever
let him go out
ever
how do you die
huh how did he die
well he was with a bunch of friends and
uh he was supposed to be in corona
they ended up in mira loma to go buy
pizza
which i still understand to this day
and
the light turned green and as they were
going
there was something in someone in the
ford explorer
coming down doing 100
so when they crossed in the middle the
explorer hit him
split the car
and everybody went like
and uh he died on the scene
he was ejected from the seat
and uh
he died right there
brain matter everywhere and stuff like
that you know and they come and knock on
our door
and explain to us what happened
then uh when we find out who did it
that's the shocker
because
the guy had killed him
just five minutes away from us i went to
high school with him
so that was that was crazy man
he was 16
when he died
and i feel like it's my fault
because
i should have been there earlier to give
him what he wanted
if i would have he'd still be here
but because i want to go you know see a
girl and do what i do you know
i lagged it
so that happened i started doing drugs
ended up in prison
my first term was five years is that is
that when your drug addiction started
yeah armed robbery
i had to support my habits so you know
armed robbery i did five years
thank you since then
i've caught a shoe term
first time up there as soon as i got
there i caught a 16-month shoot term
i went on from there
i've been in the bay
been in high desert
i've done multiple shoot terms it's
nothing i'm proud of you know
and it took for me you know
a lot of my years a lot of my youth you
know who are in prison for armed robbery
arm robber yeah all my uh convictions
are robberies
um
i got a six-year-old son
and uh
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] you know
because if i wasn't if i was a man
you know i'd be there for my kid
you know
i'd be a provider
you know
i'd be somebody
but to this day i can't sit there and
call myself man anybody out there trying
to call themselves a man that don't pay
bills
don't take care of the kids ain't no
[ __ ] man
you think you're a man because [ __ ]
you know how to fight or
you don't let nobody tell you what to do
you ain't no [ __ ] man
you and i both know what a real man
consists of
you know because i didn't know what that
was
i lost my son my baby's mom
and uh
to this day you know it hurts it kills
me
because i know i love my son
but my actions stay different
you know i'm not gonna sit there a lot
of myself
i'm not
you know
i can't
i love my son but my actions are
different so i sit there and i say how
could you love somebody that you you
don't even try to take care of
how can you say you love that person
you know
it's like
it's it's true
you know
if i loved him i'd do enough to be there
for him you know i wouldn't have [ __ ]
off my life or been like
oh it's okay i'll take care of it later
i'll do it later when's the last time
you saw your son
he's six years old man and uh
he was almost one when i was with him
i only maybe spent about
six months with him
and uh my baby's mom left me
because i cheated on her
you know the day i walked up to the door
it was locked
all the locks were changed in the house
i knocked on the door she opened it she
goes yes
i go can i come in my own house and
she's like no i gave you everything you
asked for ricardo you turn around and
spit in my face
try to apologize
you know and she's like
not having it you know and
i go can i talk to you at least she's
like you could talk to me in front of my
family and i said no
me being mean having a big eagle and and
like oh i'm cute i'm handsome you know i
could do better than that i get another
[ __ ] you know and down the way you know
that's what my mind and my that's how i
used to think and because of that i lost
a lot of good people in my life
you know
i lost my son the only thing that was
important to me
you know and uh
that [ __ ] hurts man you know
i come from
i come from a hard life you know
but that doesn't make it okay
or make any excuse for me to be like oh
well i get high because of my life or
this this and that that
that's that's took me a while to learn
that but i learned that
i learned that you know that
that you know there are people like me
in worship positions that are doctors
nurses
have their businesses
you know so it's like what was my excuse
you know
i was too busy too stupid you know
and too self-centered selfish
you know that i was just me me me me me
me me
i'm hurt i'm this on that so everybody
should pay attention to me
everybody should listen to me everybody
should feel sorry for me
and it don't work like that
you know recently um
my grandma
my grandma all my grandma said was you
know she look at me i just want you to
do good good me ho you know she's done
everything for me
in prison nobody was there for me but my
grandma
money on my books
packages everything and all she wanted
was that i get a job and i take care of
myself
and i couldn't even do that because i
cared about my habit my addiction more
than anything else
so uh
i seen her one day and she was coughing
you know and i asked her what was wrong
and she was like i'm sick on the colbert
thing
i was sick too
she looked at me and she goes
you got me sick
i said i'm sorry grandma
the next day
she's in the coma
she died like a week later
because of
me
because i was wearing a mask
i gotta live with that [ __ ] every day
every day you know
i guess you could say you know i
i should have made a difference when i
had the chance
i had every opportunity
to make something of myself
a lot of people get the choice the
chances that i got
not a lot of people get that
i did
and i burned them all
because i cared about my addiction more
than anything else
so
because of that you know i lost
everything
everything
you know and
it just it sucks because i wish i could
have made my grandma happy before she
died you know she didn't want nothing
else but to know that i was okay
that she could die peacefully
knowing that she'd have to worry about
me
because that's all i had my whole life
she was my mom my grandmother my best
friend
everything
nobody else would do nothing for me but
her
i could call her in the middle of the
night she picked me up 97 year old lady
what kind of piece of [ __ ] am i
you're calling her late as [ __ ]
to come pick me up
or or bring me 30 dollars because i'm
sick
when she's old you know
she had to work still
just to take care of me
she shouldn't have to work we should be
the ones to take care of her
she had to drive clean houses every day
just to make sure i ate
i'm thankful for it i really am but
again i actually say different
know
i want change
i want to be different you know
i want to be a productive member of
society because i still have a good head
on my shoulders
despite my habits
my drug use
i'm thankful that i still have a good
head on my shoulders
and i have a job
i'm homeless yeah you know
recently
but
i'm glad that at least have
a source of income
you know
despite being homeless and being on the
streets you know
at least i got a job
but
you know i guess you could say it's too
late you know
i hadn't [ __ ] everything up that was
given to me then
and
i'm at that point you know where i'm
just like
like i'm fed up i'm fed up man
i got to make a difference i have to i'm
32 years old bro and i got nothing to
show for it
nothing
i don't got [ __ ] nothing
that's embarrassing
it's not too late
of course it's not you're so young man
yeah you're right you know that that's
why i said i got a good head on my
shoulder still
because of that no i can still do things
you know
you'd be surprised how
people's capacity to forgive
and forget
is pretty great
yeah if somebody like you turned to turn
your life around
became a better father became a better
man
out here people treat you very
differently yeah
they would
yeah you're right i'm not saying it's
easy to do you know with an opiate
addiction but it is
something that you can change
that's yeah you're right you know what
it would change everything else
you've you know changed how you feel
about yourself
you know yeah you'd be proud of yourself
yeah because
you're depressed ashamed of yourself
yeah
there's gotta be a lot of shame in your
whole situation there's a lot of [ __ ]
man
there's a lot you're not the grandson
you want to be you're not the father you
want to be
right now i got something else that my
son calls the head
i'm sorry i got there's someone else
that myself is calling dad right now
yeah
i didn't want that to happen they used
to warn me too
do you want somebody else calling
do you want somebody do you want your
son to be calling someone else dad
i sit there and be like [ __ ] no i don't
want that [ __ ]
to do something
because
before you know it
he's gonna be calling somebody else dead
and it happened
it happened i lost them
and that [ __ ] it hurts you know and
for a while you know i sat there it was
like
poor me poor me poor me you know but i
wouldn't do nothing
to change it you know
and
that was the hard part
you know so
the first step was admitting you know i
had a problem
you know accepting it you know
and
talking about it
because i've noticed that
people don't like to talk about their
past or things like that because it's of
course it's embarrassing you know but
i've learned that you have to in order
to let that go
or else you're going to be stuck
you're going to just
be in the hole
in
in the past
you can't do that
you know
[Music]
don't go anywhere
i've been looking for you
[Music]
ruby
yeah so ricardo you can you can turn
your life around you're still a young
man yeah and you can make yourself proud
you can even make your son proud
believe it or not
yeah
i want to that's that's what that's what
i plan on doing you know i i know that
i can prove my baby's mom wrong you know
i could show her you know
that that i can be somebody you know for
my son yeah you should use that
incredible challenge
yeah as like a goal yeah turn
the whole world is saying that you're a
fuck-up yeah
and you can't do it no
and you should you just make it your
mission
to prove everybody wrong prove everybody
wrong yeah
exactly because i know like you know i
know what she was thinking you know
i don't got to put him on child support
for what he got no [ __ ] job
you know
and if i put him on child support that
means that i got to deal with him still
she didn't even do that
she didn't put me on sauce she just
disappeared
she told me once she goes
ricardo
i disappeared on you once before for two
years
she goes
what makes you think i won't do a
lifetime
she goes
remember this
i don't need you
you need us
you need this family
she goes you sat there and begged me for
a family
and i gave that to you
and i sat there
and i
laid back and said let's see what he
does with it
you didn't do [ __ ] but hurt us
that was deep that was hard
because she was right
you know
but on the other hand too
she had a problem um
she was really abusive
with me
uh she put her hands on me a lot
uh despite you know her being very
christian and stuff like that you know
and and being by the bible and
you know
10 mandatory of our checks goes to our
tides
every check 10 percent go to the church
um
she was a type of woman that uh
monday
was a marriage counseling to prepare us
for marriage
tuesday was bible study for adults
wednesday was the bible study for the
youth
so i go as an example and give my five
minutes of fire let them know you don't
want to be like me
um
thursday
uh was like a
church at night time and then they would
sell food and stuff like that
then friday saturday sunday church two
times a day
yeah i mean some people are holy rollers
and they're just into it yeah that's
their whole family i'm not but but if
you used
all the
you know you you've caused a lot of pain
and you feel a lot of pain
from your actions right yeah
you should use that pain you feel as
fuel
and channel it into something
destructive because you're still a young
man yeah
i did go to school and stuff like that
yeah if i you're 32 yeah if i was 32 i
would conquer the world
i really would
knowing what i know now
yeah
but safety you should you should take
every bit of your
pain and regret that you feel and shame
and turn it into
you know just channel it and put all
your energy into creating
yeah a new ricardo
yeah you're right
i i just wish you a great father for
your son and maybe you'll have another
child down the road if you're still
young yeah
she uh
was really abusive you know like uh
for instance um no one's perfect
and you don't you don't need to pull her
under the
bus either but
oh man if i didn't get if if i didn't go
on the front of the church and get on my
knees let them pray for me when we got
home she whipped my ass yeah well well
every everyone's got a different belief
system and style but whatever that's
your thing yeah and you can't
you can't say she's right or wrong it
works for her and maybe it doesn't work
for other people yeah but i'm just
talking about ricardo right now yeah
i was don't blame anybody no i don't
know by myself forgive everyone
including yourself yeah clean the slate
start over yeah you're right you know i
mean you got a monkey on your back but
but that doesn't mean you can't shake it
yeah you're right you know
i sit back and think you know what i'm
like man i was given every opportunity
everything i don't know but see
every word that you're saying is is just
piling on more guilt on your [ __ ] on
your
on your head
and you shouldn't feel guilt i mean you
should feel guilty but you should also
just turn it into
like
this isn't about me but here's how i
handle adversity like every
every bad thing that happens to me in
one way or another
is my
responsibility
every every negative thing that i've
ever been through
i could choose to see it as 100 my
responsibility as you can too
and once i've done that
then i can make two decisions
i can continue to do the same thing and
repeat that pattern or i can
channel it
into
a way of seeing it as man i never want
that to happen again yeah
i never want to
get screwed over on a contract i never
want to get a divorce again i never want
to
you know betray anyone or whatever you
know i i never want to hurt
i never want to hurt anyone else or
myself ever again
so i do things about my
my behavior
to do things differently in the future
and and the pain and the regret that i
feel by doing those things
is the the fuel
to never do it again and you can do
you're in the same you're in a great
position right now to do a
whole 180 on your life
yeah you're right yeah live things
differently yeah i mean look at you you
don't even look like a drug addict once
you get your teeth fixed you're not a
drug addict yeah i got someone hitting
me no i don't mind
that happens to 99.9 percent of people
that are doing drugs in one way or
another they lose their teeth for
whatever for whatever reason you [ __ ]
just came out
but but
you could see a dentist and get it all
fixed up and look at you you're a
handsome young man
if you if you somehow kicked it
man i can tell you ricardo your life
would be beautiful
and how old is your son
he's six
man
he's still a little kid
let's say you got yourself clean
totally clean and
somehow you get back into your
in contact with your son and your your
ex-wife and
and
you you could be a part of your son's
life again even though he's got you know
his mom's got a new dad
a new husband um
you could
you could connect with your son again
and you'd feel so much better about
yourself your son would be proud of
proud of you
you could rebuild your life
you can do it
yeah
you're right
what's with what's crazy is um
i remember uh telling myself uh it's
about my mom um
i said if my mom would just had stayed
alive
long enough for me
to have grown up
i told myself i would have supported her
habit
just as long as i would they wouldn't
keep her home if if
if supporting her habit and getting her
whatever she needed kept her home
gave me a mom
i would have did that
but i was told that she tried to sell me
at one point you know so
and uh i remember one day
i was on my girl's phone
and i go
i wonder why her family has never tried
to look for me you know
so
i started looking you know i type in
rosemary controlla
and this lady pops up
i screenshot it this is where my grandma
was alive i said picture my grandma and
great grandma who's this
she looks and she goes that's your mom
and i go it is her huh she goes where
did you get this and then go i found her
and she goes no no no no no no no no in
spanish she's like do not talk to leave
her alone there's a reason why they
don't talk to us and we don't talk to
them
i go i know but i have questions you
know you know so i sent the message
no reply i send another message and i go
i go hello to whom this may concern i go
if your name is rosemary controlla i
think you're my mother
and then i leave my number there
i get a call like 10 minutes later
is this ricardo i go yes who's this
she goes oh my god miho we got a pc your
mom you got a piece of your mom and i'm
like who's this she goes i'm your aunt
i go oh wow
she goes yeah
she i'm your aunt she goes oh my god she
goes
i gotta tell everybody so now she's
telling all these people i got all these
cousins and i got another grandmother
and then i meet her brother
my uncle
his name is ray and uh
but not in person they live in texas and
then the atm and then whatever they live
in whittier so um
i start talking all these people and
[ __ ] you know and at this point i'm not
telling my grandmother
and they they're telling me like they
got a a family reunion coming up and uh
they made it known that i'm here you
know so now everybody's gonna be coming
from [ __ ] buffalo egypt and all that
just to see
me
and um
so i'm talking to ray and i go what i
told you about keeping my mom i told him
that
and he goes miho he's uh she would have
just did you dirty
or sold you for some dope
that's how she was
she wouldn't change it no matter what
mijo
he goes all she would have did was just
hurt you and i was just like man i
wouldn't give a [ __ ] just as long as i
could at the end of the day say i got a
mom she's at home
and he was like yeah senate go can i ask
you a question
he goes yeah i go
it took me five minutes to find you guys
five minutes
and i already know anything about you
guys
besides first and last names
i go
why don't you kind of look for me
ask both of them then
why don't you guys look for me the first
thing my own goals is she was mijo your
mom loved you despite what she did she
loved you i remember the day where i
hopped she was crying because she missed
you and loved you and this listen nah
not my man she's pulled as [ __ ] she was
crying cause she was probably kicking
dope she wasn't feeling good
and then uh she goes i can't blame him
for what you're saying me oh i
understand you're upset and this this
and that and i'm like i'm upset man
it took me five minutes to find you
[ __ ]
why didn't you guys look for me
oh well we weren't sure if we lived at
that house still i go what house they
knew exactly where my grandma's house
was
i was always outside so i go what's your
excuse she goes they both say
well we had issues with your family
meeting my uncle
and they basically said they were scared
of him they were scared to show up to
the house because of him
i go that that's not acceptable man i
said it took me five minutes to find you
guys you know
you guys never even care to look for me
nothing
you know
don't sit there and say you guys tried
you know because you didn't you know i
could forget it yeah but you're you're
talking like a victim right now
yeah i know and that victim mentality
you know where it'll keep you in five
ten fifteen years [ __ ] spot right
where you're at right now yeah
i just wanted you guys questions
you got to drop that like
like a hot call man no yeah yeah this
kid i'm i'm just telling you my
experiences you know what this is no i
mean victim victim victim yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i got two seconds for that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah you should too you should just drop
it
because you want to see yourself as a
victim go ahead no but you know where
you're being 20 years [ __ ] no you know
what your son will be saying about you
the same thing you're saying about your
mom
yeah you're right think about it
you're right man
so time is now recorded
yeah the time is now
i've taken some steps you know since
then you know uh you know i got myself a
job you know i got that on my own you
know
um
i plan on going back to school that's
great
you know eventually you know
i say it you know but i actually got to
apply myself yeah
go from there man you know it's great
you can do it my addiction is just i'm
on fentanyl and methadone
yeah no fentanyl is no joke methadone
isn't either yeah no
no you you've got
you got some serious obstacles in your
in your face but
that doesn't mean you can't do it
not just for your son and not for your
grandmother
and not to prove anybody wrong
[Music]
well i've learned you do it for ricardo
you can't do nothing for nobody but
yourself yeah you do it for yourself and
if you do it for for yourself and make
yourself
proud i feel you you have a whole chain
of people they think you're
amazing
[Music]
you're right
you're right
and the person leading that parade
is going to be your son
i got something to work forward to you
know to look forward to yes you do my
son you know
and your future yeah
you know because
you see where this lifestyle you're
leading is gonna take you
okay
the other day man
you know how many the officer told me
this he goes he goes
because he see me looking
some of the same thing you did he's like
you like what you see
i said no
he goes i seen you off in deep thoughts
you're staring like oh yeah i am
i was all just thinking about the other
day because they found some dead body
right there in the tent that was there
for two weeks he goes yeah you'd be
surprised man he goes how many dead
bodies you think right now are in these
tents
because you you say you might have just
walked past a few tents right now and
three people dead in there
just like that you're doing the drug
that
that puts people there
and he looks at me and he goes
what are you doing down here
the way i'm dressing [ __ ] dude what are
you doing down here
you're getting high or what
and i i laughed i said nah man then he
looks at me and he goes look man
tell you he goes
this this this life here isn't for you
man he just he looked at me and he said
that and he goes whatever you're doing
dude he goes
you need to stop now before you end up
like that or like that he's exactly
right and you know it yeah you don't
need to be told
by me or a cop or anybody else
you know deep down your heart
what to do
everybody does yeah you just need
a lot of courage
it's not about anybody else it's not
about any of your family it's not about
your friends
it's all about you the only one that's
going to do it is you and no one's going
to help you
and no one's going to make it easier
and it's up to you
yeah
just shut up and do it don't talk about
it yeah don't talk about anything
actually speak louder
you can't help someone that don't want
to help themselves
yep
all right thank you
thanks ricardo yes sir
you